Let’s discuss the human vision system. Now
I am not a biologist, so I am going to give
you an engineer’s impression of how the
human vision system works.
Firstly we have the eye itself, and looking
at an eye perhaps the most obvious feature
is the white part, which is called the sclera,
and the iris. Now the sclera is fibrous tissue,
which is an important part of the structure
of the eye and some kinds of animals the sclera
actually has bony components in it and in
this fossil here you can see a ring of bone,
which is actually part of the sclera of that
animal’s eye.
If we look at the cross section of the eye
on the right here, we can see that the sclera
which is part of the membrane that surrounds
the eyeball itself. We can see the iris and
the pupil which regulates the light going
into the eye. We can see the lens, which is
a transparent, crystalline protein structure
which focuses the light onto the retina on
the back of the eye.
The inside of the eye is filled with a fairly
transparent fluid, and at the back of the
eye we have a surface which is called the
retina, a curved surface which contains the
photoreceptors, that is, the light sensitive
part of the eye. And that is then connected
by this big nerve bundle—the optic nerve—to the brain.
In fact, we can actually think
of the eye as being a part of the brain. It
is connected by a significant nerve bundle,
and then the eye is essentially a sensory
part of the brain located in the front of
our heads.
Let’s now look in more detail at the retina
of the eye. So if we take a transect, we move
from inside the eye to outside of the eye
along the direction of that arrow we pass
through a number of layers of cells and blood
vessels and whatever. Now this is all on a
pretty small scale; this total structure is
about 500 microns thick.
The light sensitive cells are at the bottom
of this structure. So they are not on the
surface of the retina, they are actually about
500 microns below the surface of the retina.
So the light has to pass through—diffuse
through—these cells and blood vessels before
it gets to the light sensitive cells.
Now you’ve probably heard people talking
about rods and cones. The rods cells and the
cone cells are the light sensitive elements.
They are the photoreceptors in our eye. The
rod cells are these spaghetti shaped structures.
They are kind of thin. And they are sensitive
to low light levels. So we use the rod cells
when we are working in a very low light environment.
The cone cells are these strange, stumpy shaped
cells; they are a little bit conical, kind
of squat, not as tall as the rods. And these
cells are sensitive to colour. And there are
three different types of cones cells: there
are some that are sensitive to red light,
some sensitive to green light and some sensitive
to blue light. But the characteristic they
all share is that they are this somewhat conical shape.
Another way we can consider the eye is to
look at where the optic fibre joins the retina
and that creates an area on the retina which
is called the optic disk where there are actually
no light sensitive cells. So there is a part
of the retina that does not respond to light.
And there is another part of the retina where
we have an enormous concentration of light
sensitive cells and that area is called the
fovea. The fovea and the optic nerve are separated
by some distance.
So in this graph here what we are going to
see is the density of photoreceptor cells,
and there is a huge peak in the number of
cone cells per square millimetre in this area
we call the fovea. So we have exquisite resolution
in this one small area of our eye. The rest
of the eye, we have much less resolution and
unconsciously our eye is continually moving,
focusing, on different parts of the scene,
directing the fovea to these different parts.
So we build up a high resolution of the image
by directing the high resolution fovea all
over the scene we are looking at.
Now with the rod cells they have a quite different
spatial density pattern. There are very few
rod cells in the fovea area, but there’s
many more rod cells in what we call our peripheral
vision; away from the direction that our eye
is pointing. This is very useful at night
and these cells are also somewhat motion sensitive.
They are what give us the ability to see something
moving out of the corner of our eye.
So what is really interesting then is this
business of the optic nerve entering the retina
and creating what we call the blind spot.
Now we can actually detect our blind spot
using a pattern, something like this. So what
you do is close your right eye and stare at
the plus sign. And then move your head toward
and away from the screen making absolutely
sure that you are looking with your left eye
at the plus sign. As you move your head in
and out, the circle here will at some point
fall onto the optic disk on your retina and
it will, quite surprisingly, it will just
disappear from view. So you can have some
fun with a test like this, you can find others
online. Have a play and see if you can find
your blind spot. It is quite surprising that
in everyday life we don’t notice that we
have got a blind spot. We go to a bit of trouble,
we can actually detect that it is there.
Now if we look at, for instance, our horizontal
cross section of the brain. We can see the
eyes located at the front of the head and
the optic nerve bundles carry the visual information
through the brain to the back part of the
brain, where we have our visual cortex. And
that is where we have all the really exciting
visual processing going on. That is where
part of our brain is responsible for recognising
people and objects and motion and so on. But
the human brain is a very complex structure.
It weighs something like 1.5 kilograms and
is about 1011 neurons in there. So an awful
lot of computation and memory capability.
Nearly a third of that is devoted to processing
visual information.
Earlier we used the argument that the eye
has been invented so many times by evolution
that it must be a very effective sensor for
animals. But there is a cost for the sense
of vision, and in the case of human beings
one of those costs is that a third of our
brain is devoted to processing this visual
information. So yes, it is a very effective
sensor that as an organism we pay quite a
cost in order to run that sensor.
Additional costs are associated with the eyes themselves.
They are very delicate structures, so we evolved mechanisms to protect the eye.
For instance,
our eyelids and eyelashes, mechanisms to clean the eyes with tear ducts and so on,
and the eyes are also moved within the head by some very high performance muscles.
So there is a lot of auxiliary machinery involved in maintaining the sense of vision.